[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parle sport l'émission qu'il ne faut
surtout pas manquer si vous êtes un
passionné de sport le sport local et
mais aussi l'actualité de nos sportifs
ivelinois au du monde entier j'ai la
lourde tâche de remplacer Michel midoro
il va très bien ne vous inquiétez pas on
pense fort à lui mais heureusement je
suis entouré d'une team de premier choix
team réduite mais de premier choix vous
aurez ici des analyses des décryptages
du débat le tout bien sûr dans la bonne
humeur et on commence à ma gauche
musique c'est un rock un cap que disje
une péninsule de cette émission le
gladiateur qui toujours bien placé dans
la mêlée s tiré le meilleur pour
analyser les sujets sur la table
élégance et détermination Pierre
Chevalier able communication du Rugby
Club de versaill est avec nous salut
pierre comment ça va for et bonheur
salut salut les amis et ben content
d'être là de tenir la baraque pendant
que que pour différentes raisons nos
copains ne sont pas présents avec nous
sur le plateau mais en forme au pluriel
toujours et et prêt à prêt à débattre
vous aurez le Brass le brassard de
capitaine aujourd'hui allez lourde tâche
je vais essayer d'en mêtre digne on
passe de l'autre côté musique il est de
retour sur TV 78 non pas pour jouer un
mauvais tour mais pour clamer son amour
du sport c'est aussi un amoureux vous
l'entendez avec ce AK de la
Nouvelle-Zélande il s'agit de sa deuxè
sélection seulement dans cette émission
mais désormais il a l'expérience d'une
coupe du monde de rugby suivie de près
pour placer de belles analyses et de
l'expérience si lui en faudra pour
prendre la suite de l'envoler puce que
vous aurez aussi la lourde tâche de me
succéder à l'envoler tout à l'heure
Nicolas d'endr de la rédaction tv78 mais
B qui est avec nous bonjour Nicolas
comment ça va bonsoir Grégory ça va très
bien bonsoir pierre bonne année à vous
d'ailleurs bonne année remplacervol et
effectivement alors vous c'est plutôt
des envolés vers les lucarnes pour
essayer d'arrêter les ballons moi ça
sera plus des envolés sous les ballons
haut essayer d'être meilleur que les
Français en quart de finale face à
l'Afrique du Sud c'est l'une des raisons
qui explique la défaite l'équipe de
France lors de la du quart de finale de
la Coupe du monde face à l'Afrique du
Sud bon on va essayer d'être très bon à
3 vous l'avez vu équipe réduite il y a
une certaines maladies qui s'appelle la
grippe en ce moment qui fait pas mal de
ravag dans les rangs on pense on pense à
fort à Jean-Michel richfort à Mike
Mokongo aussi qui devait être avec nous
aujourd'hui au menu du jour messieurs je
vous propose du football la ville de
Montini le Bretonneux accueillera-t-elle
le futur stade du PSG nos confrères de
l'équipe avanceent cette piste si le
club venait à quitter le Parc des
Princes vous y croyez ou non je vous
poserai la question tout à l'heure du
tennis aussi avec de nouvelles
déceptions malheureusement pour nos
ivelinois Caroline Garcia et Arthur
inderknes à l'Open d'Australie les JO ça
se rapproche j- 184 désormais avant
Paris 2024 4 et on commence à connaître
les noms des porteurs de la flamme
olympique on parlera aussi de ça tout à
l'heure et sans oublier bien sûr je le
disais Nicolas l'envolé votre envolé et
je crois que vous allez nous parler de
rugby vous nous en direz t plus tout à
l'heure voilà j'ai du mal à commencer
mais on va on va débuter justement cette
émission par du
basket qui n'a jamais rêvé de défier son
meilleur copain dans l'une des plus
prestigieuses compétitions du monde
c'est ce qui est arrivé le 20 janvier
dernier à livelinois Victor wanama et à
son ami Bilal Coulibali les deux pépites
du basket français qui se sont côtoyés
au MET 92 de Boulogne Levallois la
saison passée se sont retrouvés en NBA
d'un côté les Wizards de Washington de
Koulibali et de l'autre les Spurs de San
Antonio de wby ça restera presque
anecdotique peut-être pas pour San
Antonio mais les Spurs l'ont emporté 131
127 sur le parquet des Wizards c'était
vraiment un rêve un moment de joie pure
on était juste fier c'est notre rêve là
de se retrouver sur le terrain l'un en
face de l'autre a déclaré Bilal
Koulibali alors c'est une belle image
pour nous de magnifiques souvenirs qui
resteront gravés dans leur mémoire tout
simplement votre avis pierre sur ces
retrouvailles moi je je trouve assez
génial que qu'on puisse en fait avec eux
franchir l'Atlantique et que et que ce
soit des Français qui toute proportion
gardé font font l'actualité en NBA on a
on a la deux copains qui devaient qui
devaient déjà avoir plein de rêves quand
ils étaient encore plus jeunes euh sur
les playground des hautes scènes
notamment et puis après se retrouver se
retrouver chez les mets et là euh là
c'est quand même là c'est là c'est le le
Graal le Graal des basketteurs mondiaux
ils sont jeunes ils sont plein de plein
d'avenir euh WBE on en parle
suffisamment souvent ici pour pour le
confirmer et puis et puis pour pour
attendre encore toujours plus de de ce
de ce golgot de ce de cette comète enfin
non même pas une comète de C de de cette
star star en devenir et B c'est c'est
c'est super attachant de de voir C ces
deuxlà qui qui commencent à réussir et
qui commence vraiment une carrière une
carrière assez dingue en NBA et petite
petite anecdote aussi c'est vous vous
l'avez rappelé mais ça n'en est pas une
les victoires des Spurs sont
suffisamment rares cette saison pour
pouvoir s'en satisfaire donc là au moins
c'est bien ils ont un petit peu rallumé
le compteur votre avis Nicolas on a vu
sur les images peut-être qu'on va
pouvoir les revoir a différence de
taille entre les deux grand talent chez
les deux mais 21 cm quand même qu'il est
ça bon il pas le même poste ça c'est pas
c'est pas un secret c'est pas le même
poste c'est pas les mêmes fonctions sur
le terrain de basket mais ce qui est
énorme dans ces images là c'est c'est
que le sport c'est aussi des amitiés
c'est deux joueurs qui ont grandi
ensemble qui ont évolué ensemble en
France qui se retrouent aux États-Unis
voilà moi ça me fait penser enfin je
vais aller sur le ballon al mais ça me
fait penser aux amitiés qu'on peut voir
dans le rugby comme Antoine Dupont et et
Anthony gelonche qui évolue au Stade
Toulousain qui joue en équipe de France
c'est ça aussi le sport d'Urs on va voir
sur les images ils sont côtoyés même dès
13 ans ils avait remporté avec la
sélection des hautes scènes un
championnat de France et déjà il
terrassait les adversaires à l'époque on
le voit sur ces images voilà c'est ça
c'est que en fait finalement il se
connaissent ils évoluent ensemble et
c'est dans le sport on a plein
d'exemples comme ça de joueurs qui sont
formés ensemble qui jouent dans les
mêmes clubs qui parfois deviennent
adversaires jouent l'un contre l'autre
mais peuvent se retrouver aussi en
sélection c'est de joueurs français qui
vont sûrement jouer en équipe de France
ensemble pour les Jeux Olympiques on
verra mais en tout cas dans les années
dans les prochaines années ils seront
ils évolueront sûrement ensemble en
équipe de France voilà après pour
revenir sur l'actualité au niveau de la
la NBA euh la situation des deux est
similaire en NBA cette saison les Spurs
sont derniers de la conférence
West les Wizards Washington Wizards de
Bilal Koulibali sont avantderniers euh
il compte 35 défaites en en 7 en 42
matchs avec 7 victoires du côté de
Washington Wizards concernant wanama en
43 matchs il a 35 défaites et seulement
h victoires effectivement c'est c'est
compliqué pour les deux joueurs qui sont
dans l'apprentissage une première saison
en NBA il faut le rappeler alors ça a
été quand même mise en avant même du
côté des États-Unis c'est c'est une
belle publicité vous en parliez tout à
l'heure pour le basket francilien parce
que c'est deux joueurs qui ont été
formés dans la région pour le basket
français aussi pour la pour la formation
exactement pour la formation La La La
Pépinière que peut que peut que que peut
mettre en place la pro ou la Pro B et et
et de les voir là aussi ça ça ça me fait
aussi faire la la passerelle très
humaine limite mononde des bisounours en
disant pourvu que ça dure aussi c'estes
ces ces amitiés là et et même en NBA où
les enjeux sont quand même là vraiment
bien différents il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de beaucoup de gros budgets en compte
euh les deux là ils sont ils sont en ils
sont en en devenir euh bon m B a déjà
bien crevé le plafond et pas que par la
taille et et c'est c'est là le nos deux
nos deux deux de nos futur tête
d'affiche du basket français et
international on peut souhaiter
effectivement alors pas pour les gios de
Paris mais peut-être pour les pour les
pour dans 4 ans euh à Los Angeles je
crois euh et puis surtout sur sur
territoire américain donc voilà en gros
c'est c'est de toute bonne augure pour
pour le sport pour ces amitiés là don
dont on parle et pour le pour la
formation
française qui qui nous qui nous sort de
bonne pépite ouais dernier mot sur la
thématique basquette ouais très
rapidement et pourquoi pas les voir
évoluer peut-être ensemble dans les
prochaines années dans la même franchise
en NBA
ouais juste un mot sur la joouie qui a
été de courte durée pour les Spurs
puisque quelques jours plus tard ils ont
subi la loi des Philadelphia Sixers
défit 133 à 123 avec une une prestation
majuscule de Joel MB le pivot des Sixers
qui inscrit 70 points battant le record
de sa franchise c'est aussi en faisant
face à ce genre de joueur là Victor
wanama a été très bon durant durant ce
match mais que il va devenir peu à peu
un géant du basket ouais ouais il faut
il faut quand même sur sur une
prestation Ixel comme ça il existe quand
même parce qu'il met 33 points sur ce
match là bon et de compes ouais donc
c'est c'est des il est dans ses stats
dans des stats habituels un petit peu
plus même en terme de points sur ses
moyennes moyennes du moment euh mais
quand on oui quand on prend quand on se
fait éclabousser comme ça avec 70 70
grains au basket c'est quand même c'est
pas c'est pas fréquent quand même sur un
même sur un même joueur ça ça nous ça
nous fait nous souvenir que le record
actuel et je sais pas siil sera battu un
jour mais de Will Chamberlin avec ses
100 points ses 100 points dans un match
c'est juste stratosphérique là sur sur
l'histoire c'était pas le même basket
c'était pas la même c'était pas la même
période mais là les 70 points faut il
faut faut les mettre et pour pour wby ça
fait ça fait bosser au moins la défense
le mot de la fin sur cette thématique
moi je vais aller chercher les raquettes
colorées je vous laisse répondre pour
dans un instant ben ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que c'est dans ces matchs comme ça
qu'on en apprend peut-être le plus en
fait c'est W baniama il est encore jeune
il vient d'arriver en NBA et c'est dans
des défaites comme ça que ben ça sert de
leçon qu'on il peut apprendre de ses
erreurs et savoir comment euh ben
rebondir après ce genre de défaite même
s'il y a de nombreuses défaites depuis
le début de la saison je pense que c'est
une saison vraiment d'apprentissage que
ce soit pour wanama ou Koulibali et
c'est dans ces matchs là où on se frotte
au plus grand que on en apprend le plus
voilà pour cette première thématique je
vous donne vos deux raquettes messieurs
parce qu'il va falloir que vous votiez
dans un instant puisquon passe tout de
suite à notre page
débat et on va parler de cette grande
information cette information qui a même
fait un grand bruit dans le monde local
même le monde français selon nos
confrères du journal L'Équipe la ville
de Montini le bretonneu ferait partie
des pistes privilégies par le
pariss-germain pour construire son futur
stade le club de la capitale souhait en
premier lieu racheter le Parc des
Princes mais si les négociations avec la
Ville de Paris n'aboutissent pas elles
semblent aujourd'hui au point mort et
bien les dirigeants qataris
travailleraient sur un possible
déménagement le terrain en question est
situé à proximité directe du Vélodrome
national de C50 anine pas CELI de
Marseille hein parce que je pense que ça
plairait pas au parisiens c'est à l'île
de loisirs de 50 ans en yeline un site
qui avait déjà été évoqué à l'époque
pour la construction du centre
d'entraînement du du PSG il y a quelques
années avant le choix de s'implanter à à
poissie l'endroit est assez vaste pour y
planter son stade de 60000 places ultra
mododernes et aussi toute l'expérience
commerciale voulue par le club autour de
l'enceinte la région î de France
propriétaire de l'île de loisir aurait
déjà donné son accord à l'agglomération
de 50 an niine et à la ville de montinéo
breteneux pour mener directement des
discussions avec les Parisiens et le
maire de Montini le Bretonneux lui est
aussi très enthousiaste sur ce dossier
regardez ce qu'il a dit dans un
communiqué de presse ne boudons pas
notre plaisir nous sommes évidemment
favorables à discuter et travailler sur
un projet ambitieux pour le territoire
les habitants et les fans cela fait
maintenant plusieurs mois que ce dossier
avance nous sommes dans un mercato avec
différentes options nous devons donc
être mesurés mais fier de la
valorisation de nos atouts dans ce
dossier le futur stade du PSG à Montini
messieur vous y croyez oui ou non vous
votez mitiger pour Pierre mitig
également pourp du point deue en fait
sur lequel on Nicolas ben écoutez on va
commencer avec vous Nicolas d'un point
de vue historique et sportif
du côté du PSG je pense que c'est pas
une bonne idée parce
que paris-germain tout simplement en
fait alors qu'est-ce que ça deviendrait
j'ai proposé on en parlait cette semaine
en rédaction mais Sky reprendre 51 en
Eveline et mettre sa Cathar en yeline
peut-être euh donc non je pense que au
niveau de l'histoire du club ça n'a pas
de de cohérence et de pertinence et je
pense même que les les fans et même les
ultras les associations d'ultra du du
parissgermain
ne sont pas favorables à cela parce que
ben on quitte Paris en fait et le PSG a
déjà aussi quitté Saint-Germain a
l'identité Saint-Germain dans le nom
parisg voilà Saint-Germain n'a plus de
raison d'être puisque maintenant ils
sont installés à poissie je sais pas
qu'est-ce qui reste du du pariss-germain
à Saint-Germain peut-être l'équipe
féminine qui va non non qui a déménagé
apr il y avait les jeunes aussi ils ont
déménagé aussi à poissi tout le monde
est à poiss donc le PSG n'est plus
existant à Saint-Germain ils sont à
poiss
maintenant ça serait la fin du du nom en
tout cas parisgermain par contre et
c'est là où je suis plutôt favorable de
l'autre côté d'un point de vue du
territoire de 50 ans iveline d'un point
de vue des Yvelines bah c'est c'est le
Graal
50 ans yelin qui accueille le stade du
parissaggermain le meilleur club actuel
en France le meilleur club de football
ah bah ça serait ça serait l'idéal et ce
serait encore un coup de projecteur qui
ferait suite aux jeux olympique puisque
ce serait bah dans les années qui
suivent les Jeux olympiques de de Paris
d'utant qu'on le voit l'image pierre bah
le PSG est maintenant installé dans son
nouveau campus de poissie on a une
vingtaine de kilomètres de de 50 ans
nelin voilà à peu près la solution n'est
pas idéale vous étiez aussi mitigé sur
sur la question d'avoir un stade à
proximité finalement de son centre
d'entraînement oui il y a il y a deux
deux réflexions et deux axes le premier
c'est vraiment du marketing pur et le
deuxième c'est plus c'est presque dirais
administratif et juridique sur le
marketing Nicolas l'a rappelé on on
passerait du PSG au mlbp Montini le
Breton poissi si on reprend en gros la
genèse de de la marque PSG alors il
faudrait il faudrait pour ça puisque
maintenant c'est c'est réellement une
marque mondialement connu évidemment pas
non seulement en France mais mais
partout dans le monde donc il faudrait
il faudrait garder cette identité là
mais avec avec maintenant avec des des
des géolocalisations un peu
différentes sportivement si si pour
faire pour faire la la la passerelle
effectivement ça serait un confort de
plus pour l'ensemble des catégories du
PSG donc pas pas que pour les garçons
mais et les filles professionnelles mais
en gros toutes les toutes les catégories
formé formé au PSG il y a il y a du sens
effectivement il y a du sens puisque il
y a il y a quand même une histoire
au-delà de Paris il y a une histoire
dans les ivelines avec avec
Saint-Germain d'abord et puis maintenant
poissi et qui et qui sait peut-être
Montin Bretonneux mais on on est plus
pour basculer sur la partie administra
et juridique sur un coup de pression je
pense que là le la la direction qatari
et et Nasser font font des effets
d'annonce à mon sens pour mettre la
pression sur la mairie de Paris parce
que si si là on remet le le le coup de
projecteur sur Paris au-delà du Parc des
Princes Paris et cetera et l'histoire
l'histoire même du
PSG que ferait la ville de Paris du Parc
des Princes si le PSG si le PSG
déménager on a en plus il en son temps
il aurait pu avoir une réflexion avec le
stade França et Paris côté rugby mais
maintenant on a un stade qui est à 10 m
jamboin est un est un joli écrin de
rugby maintenant et qui fonctionne qui
fonctionne aussi avec d'autres avec
d'autres activités et notamment celle
d'accueillir le pour l'instant le FC
Versailles en football mais donc donc en
gros qui pourrait exploiter utiliser le
Parc des Princes si ce n'est le PSG
actuellement donc je pense que c'est le
le dossier le dossier Stade de France là
en l'occurrence c'est aussi un petit peu
un petit peu enterré parce que fa parti
des pistes a
mais pour plein de raisons c'est pas
c'est peut-être ça serait presque même
moins moins évident de de rentabiliser
et de pousser le projet au au Stade de
France que de construire un stade à
Montini le Breton par exemple mais pour
rejoindre pierre et pour pousser plus
loin au-delà de du côté juridique et de
de l'avenir du du Parc des Princes et
par rapport à la mairie de Paris la
mairie de Paris a aussi un gros enfin le
PSG c'est un gros gain pour le la mériie
de Paris au niveau de l'image au niveau
de l'aspect il y a des tour is qui
viennent à Paris juste pour le PSG mais
le PSG de l'autre côté veut son stade de
propriété qu'on peut comprendre aussi
parce que pour se iser au niveau des des
autres clubs de rang international il
faut un stade de de propriété
propriétaire de son stade propriétaire
de son stade mais là aussi où il y a des
contraintes juridiques et puis en terme
d'urbanisme aussi c'est que ils veulent
être propriétaire de leur stade mais ils
veulent aussi agrandirou le parc des
princesv parce que comme comme Pierre
l'a dit le stade jambon est à 10 m
comment agrandir le Parc des Princes et
faire des travaux réaliser des travaux
au Parc des Princes aujourd'hui enfin
par rapport à la situation le
périphérique en dessous et avec le
périphérique en dessous donc il y a
cette problématique là
aussi après je pense que le PSG trouve
va trouver une solution s'il y a des
travaux qui sont engagé au Parc des
Princes pour aller jouer peut-être au
stade de charletti je sais pas mais mais
voilà la mairie de Paris a quand même un
intérêt économique et d'attractivité
parce que il y a des touristes
aujourd'hui qui viennent du monde entier
qui viennent notamment pour le
parisaingermain niveau transport si on
regarde les infrastructures alors sans
bouchon Montini et Paris on peut on peut
rejoindre une vingtaine de minutes à
proximité il y a la 12 et la 13 la
commune et dervieussi par plusieurs
lignes de transport en commun le RORC
les lignes n etu du Transilien la ligne
18 passera non loin de là à l'horizon
2030 est-ce que les infrastructures sont
suffisantes pour vous dans le cas alors
voilà on est vraiment dans l'hypothèse
si jamais le stade se construit là pour
accueillir le flot de supporters
suffisante sans doute et on verra
d'ailleurs sur un premier test grandeur
nature grandeur mondiale pendant les
gios notamment sur toutes les épreuves
olympiques qui sont organisé dans les
Yvelines mais rien à voir par rapport au
confort et au et à la la praticité du
Parc des Princes pour Paris pour les
supportes parisiens à part la la on va
dire à part la capacité de parking on va
dire pour ceux qui VI qui viendra en
voiture mais en métro bus bus entre
autres et et les r qui arrivent qui
arrivent vraiment pas loin ce le Parc
des Princes concentre tous les avantages
en l'occurrence là-dessus que l'aspect
environnemental aussi à prendre en
compte on est dans une zone Natura 2000
qui est protégée il y a plusieurs
espèces d'oiseaux qui sont à proximité à
l'île de loisir on se souvient à
l'époque de la recherche du nouveau
centre d'entraînement notamment à Ti ver
valalgriignon qui est un aut site il y
avait une levée de bouclier au niveau de
l'environnement là c'est un aspect aussi
à prendre en compte pour une lois ASP à
prendre en compte après le feu vert sera
donné par la région île-de-franance
puisque le Conseil départemental des
Yvelines et 5quenttins en Yveline qui
était engagé dans le Syndicat de Gestion
de l'île de loisirs et bien ce sont
désengagés maintenant c'est la région
qui prend le L et qui est propriétaire
et seul propriétaire et seul
gestionnaire de de l'île de loisirs donc
la la région a laissé à cqus en Yveline
engager les discussions avec le club
directement donc la région n'est pas
intermédiaire mais en revanche le
dernier mot sera donné par la région
île-defance ça c'est concernant l'aspect
jurididique disons de l'île de loisirs
mais sur les transports bah après il
faut regarder ce qui se fait en Europe
en Angleterre à Londres vous avez pas un
allez Standford bridge peut-être le
stade de de Chelsea c'est le seul stade
qui est vraiment en presque en cœur de
ville sinon le reste des stadiums le
stade de West Ham c'est le stade
olympique de Londres et bien c'est à
l'extérieur de la ville et tous les
stades sont à l'extérieur tckenham c'est
le stade de rugby est à l'extérieur de
la ville donc 20 minutes pour aller
jusqu'au stade du du PSG ça serait pas
choquant si on regarde ce qui se fait en
Europe mais on peut mettre une petite
pièce que c'est ce finalement ce
peut-être ce coup de blufff aura aura
peut-être réussi à faire à faire avancer
le dossier qui est là qui est là figé
depuis quelques quelques semaines
quelques mois et et de de remettre la la
ville de Paris et le PSG autour de la
table et a priori de trouver une
solution sur le Parc des Princes à
priori c'est ce qui serait pour le PSG
va rester au Parc des Princes je pense
que oui c'est c'est un c'est un ouais un
coup de pression un coup de bluff
gagnant et qui permettra au PSG de
rester au ça c'est d'ordre politique he
oui en plus je le disais un stade du PSG
à côté d'un Vélodrome je sais pas si ça
passerait auprès des des supporters vous
nous avez donné aussi vos suggestions
sur pourquoi pas un nom qui pourrait
être le nouveau du parisint-germain on
verra et vous saatar en Yveline on va
bien sûr
suivre avec attention qui reste
aujourd'hui encore hypothétique alors on
va continuer messieurs cette page débat
avec du tennis la saison à redémarré
avec l'Open d'Australie où deux de nos
ivelinois étaient en LCE malheureusement
pour eux et pour nous l'aventure s'est
très vite arrêté le premier tour c'était
pourtant bien déroulé bien passé pour
Caroline Garcia on va voir ses résultats
la native de Saint-Germain enle avait
battu la japonaise Naomi Osaka double
vainqueur du tournoi du grandchlem et
qui était de retour sur les cours après
15 mois d'absence succès en 2 76 4 76 où
la numéro 1 française s'est montré très
solide mais presque tout a été balayé
d'un revers de main au tour suivant avec
vous le voyez encore Caroline Garcia qui
a craqué face à la à la Polonaise
magdaalena frche si on peut revoir les
résultats s'afficher s'il vous plaît en
régie une défaite en 2 7 6 4 76 face à
la 69e joueuse mondiale où au contraire
bien cette fois-ci Caroline Garcia a
paru fébrile de l'autre côté dans le
tableau masculin autre désillusion autre
défaite pour le tennis français le
tennis syvelinois Arthur inderkneg qui a
été sorti dès le premier tour le
saint-germainois qui est 94e au
classement ATP a été défait par le 64e
joueur mondial le russe Pavel Kotov le
Français a été combatif mené 2 7 à0 il a
sauvé une première balle de match avant
de revenir à hauteur de son adversaire
dans la rencontre il a finalement cédé
dans le 5e set score final 75 61 67 67
63 la question sur cette thématique
est-ce qu'on peut parler de réel flop de
nos deux Français de nos deux ivelinois
sur ce
tournoi réponse qui ne fait voilà aucun
doute pour vous bah pierre pourquoi
c'est un flop pour malheureusement oui
on parle souvent souvent d'Arthur à l'OP
d'Australie au départ il y a 3 ans
c'était en terme assez
élogieux depuis on a du mal on a du mal
à pouvoir à s'entousiasmer sur le sur le
niveau et les performances
d'Arthur pour Caroline c'était même on
était allé dans les dans les plus hautes
sphères avec avec ses victoires
notamment en
Masters là bon elle passe quand même un
tour on va dire pour pour Arthur c'est
un un match un match marathon mais qu'il
perd au final et et làprès que éclipser
alors moi je me je me rassureraai et me
contenterai de au niveau non plus
départemental mais national de du petit
du petit Arthur Cazo et de ses de ses
performances qui aurait pu aller même
même encore un petit peu plus loin voilà
encore à nouveau une une une petite
pépite donc qui va falloir suivre de
près en espérant que qu'il confirme vite
mais pour nos deux îles villinois oui
malheureusement malheureusement on peut
pas enessortir vraiment vraiment quelque
chose de positif ou ou un espoir en
disant on on verra on verra sur les
autres tournois du grandchlem par
exemple ou au moins les les autres
Masters mais ouais c'était un peu
décevant gros flop le la seule peut-être
éclairci c'est ce match où Arthur
inderkn est revenu malheureusement
effectivement il le perd au final mais
il a su quand même exister dans ce match
Carlin Garcia aussi avait fait un très
beau premier tour sur cette Open
d'ustralie en fait on revient toujours
au même problème et je crois que ça a
été évoqué dans dans les grande gueule
du sport chez nos confrères de RMC que
Arthur manarino manarino a travaillé
psychologiquement ces dernières années
pour revenir à un bon niveau manarino
revient à un bon niveau ces derniers ces
derniers temps grâce à un travail
psychologique et moi je pense que le
problème de nos tennisman et tennis
woman de notre tennis woman yvelinois et
ben c'est c'est psychologique en fait et
Caroline Garcia c'est pas la première
fois qu'on voit qu'il y a une grosse
performance et puis après il y a une
contre performance d'ailleurs je la cite
he elle a dit je joue une fille qui est
moins bien classée que moi pourquoi je
me mets dans des états pareils j'en sais
rien en fait dans une certaine période
c'est comme ça et je n'arrive pas à
passer au-dessus de ça c'est c'est
purement mental c'est mental c'est
mental c'est clairement mental le tennis
c'est c'est ça en fait ça se passe dans
la tête un premier set remporté il faut
savoir le tenir la rencontre c'est pas
parce qu'on a gagné le premier set que
derrière et bien il faut se reposer sur
les lauriers le tennis c'est en de sets
et c'est en 3 sets chez les garçons donc
il faut savoir tenir un match mais c'est
comme dans tous les sports j'ai envie de
dire un match de foot ça dure 90 minutes
un match de rugby ça dure 80 minutes et
c'est pas une mi-temps et puis après on
niste plus sur la deè mi-temps c'est la
régularité en fait le sujet et le
problème après pour pour citer à nouveau
manarino c'est que c'est que derrière il
prend Joko et puis et puis il prend ils
prennent des bulles ils prennent des
bulles donc c'est c'est c'est les
montagnes russes en fait en gros dans
les dans les performances avec ouais
parfois parfois des des coups d'éclat
exemple Arthur Cazo sur son sur ses
premiers tours et puis oui et puis
manarino qui qui finit par par en
rigoler mais mais qui prend une qui
prend une démo face à face à Djokovic et
après pour qu'on regarde les derniers
résultats le meilleur résultat de
l'année 2023 pour Arthur in darkn c'est
une victoire au Zug Challenge Tour
challenger tour et Caroline Garcia fait
une finale à monter qu'elle perd contre
Dona vekic 3e mondial à ce moment-là en
3 sets nous a habitué à faire des
comebacks c'était le cas sur l'année
2022 on va chercher ce titre Masters
l'an dernière c'est vrai que c'était une
saison blanche pour elle vous y croyez
un enem comeback ou c'est trop tard pour
elle elle a encore quelques belles
années devant elle a que 30 ans caring
pourquoi pas après il faut travailler
avec peut-être un préparateur mental
c'est c'est ça le sujet c'est la
régularité des performances c'est ne pas
s'effondrer après après une
contreperformance c'est oui c'est savoir
rebondir assez rapidement mais il y a
pas que ça aussi il y a l'aspect
physique s'il fallait parler par exemple
de Nadal tentative de de retour de Nadal
comeback euh et on sait que là le
problème était physique et ça ça
sembleêtre confirmé c'estàd qu'en plus
en plus ça la la machine la machine a
pas tenu donc et voilà voilà une bête
une bête mentale et et un sportif de
très très haut niveau il l'a
suffisamment montré pendant sa carrière
mais là là il y a
vraisemblablement espérons pour la suite
mais vraisemblablement le le le corps le
corps distop là à ce momentlà donc
subtile alliage entre le physique et le
physique et le mental pour l'instant les
nos Français arrive pas à avoir les deux
les deux en même temps et sur Arthur
inderknes alors vous parliez de ses
belles années 2020 2021 2022 il avait
gagné des titres
challenger effectué aussi des finales
ATP bon qu'il a perdu il sétaitissé
jusqu'au 46e rang mondial c'est
aujourd'hui son plus haut classement au
niveau ATP pour quelqu'un on le rappelle
qui est rentré tard sur le circuit à
seulement 25 ans on a quand même
l'impression j'aimerais vous entendre
sur sur ça qu'il a atteint un certains
plafond de verre on ne voit pas
forcément aller plus haut et finalement
il a peut-être obtenu déjà le maximum
qu'il pouvait déjà dans sa car qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez Nicolas je pense que
c'est le cas parce que quand on regarde
les résultats l'année dernière Open
d'Australie s'arrête au premier tour
Roland Garos s'arrête au 2è tour
Wimbledon 1er tour et US Open 3è tour
c'est son meilleur résultat en grand
Chem 3è tour à l'US Open voilà on sait
on sait qu'il a il a commencé sa
carrière de tennisman plus tard que tous
les autres avec avec d'autres sports
d'autres sports qu'il faisaent avant et
il commence par par un coup d'éclart et
dont on dont on parlait dont on parlait
encore récemment sur la sur le l'Open
d'Australie
ouais là là là en gros c'est au minimum
même si c'est pas le plat de fond de
vert c'est une courbe de progression qui
est qui est vraiment flat et qui qui qui
mériterait qui mériterait un nouveau
coup d'éclat mais est-ce que est-ce que
c'est possible quel que soit le tournoi
là pour l'instant en tout cas ça ne
s'est pas passé en 2023 on va croiser
les doigts pour 2024 arthurkn on le
disait redescendu au 94e rang mondial
qui sur les cours en ce moment à l'heure
où on enregistre sur cette émission les
cours de l'Open de Quimper et pour
Caroline Garcia con quand même qu'elle
est aller jusqu'en quart de finale de
l'Open d'Australie mais en double avec
Christina Mladenovic l'Open d'Australie
qui se termine pour la finale dame le 27
janvier la finale homme le 28 janvier je
vous donne les personnes les les les
tennis man tennis woman qui restent sur
le tableau alors côté femme l'américaine
cocogos la Russe Alexa sabalenka
shabalenka l'Ukrainienne yastemka et la
Chinoise kinwen che les hommes jokovic
CER medvedef et sverev qui s'est
qualifié au dép vias qui vient sortir
nostic sur le tableau féminin masculin
sur le tableau féminin moi coco gos
peut-être j' dire ça chez les femmes
mais moi Jef là qui
est pense ça sera dokovic Z Djokovic
allez moi je mets une petite pièce sur C
j'espère qu'il va enfin remporter un
premier tourno du Grand
lui il va perdre j'aurais pas dû
j'aurais pas dû mettre ma pièce sur lui
lui qui enchaîne quand même quelques
bons résultats dernièrement sur le
circuit mondial allez on passe à la
prochaine thématique
[Musique]
j- 284 avant 184 184 même j'ai rajouté
une centaine avant les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 une échéance attendue avec
impatience avant même la cérémonie
d'ouverture on le rappel prévu le 26
juillet les épreuves qui on lieu dans le
département les ivines vont accueillir
le 23 juillet le relais de la flamme
olympique elle traversera 8 villes 7
flamme olympique Versailles poissie
Saint-Germain en lait les Mureau Guy en
cours Rambouillet Manent laaville et
Saint-Rémi les chevreuses et il y aura
en tout plus de 100 éclaireurs dans les
ivines c'est le nom qu'on donne au
porteur de la flamme olympique on
connaît désormais l'identité des
premiers porteurs de la flamme car six
ont été choisis par le département des
Yvelines alors vous allez voir leur
visage sesffichers sont pas forcément
connus du grand public mais on va les
présenter Roger Giquel peut-être le plus
connu 92 ans porteur de la flamme
olympique au jeux de Grenoble c'était
les jeux d'hivers en
1968 figure associative et de
l'athlétisme à Saint-Germain en lait l'
rambolitaine Manon chanlu 15 ans qui est
suivie par les services de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance du département
depuis 10 ans elle est judocate et elle
est passionnée par les chevuxx
ambitionne de devenir pompier Jonathan
Lefèbre 40 ans agent de sensibilisation
au handicap au sein de la commune des
mureaux il pratique le paronbal depuis
ses 16 ans Annique vatrin 93 ans qui est
impliquée depuis toujours dans la vie
associative de mantelaville elle a
également pratiqué la danse jusqu'à ses
90 ans enfin clémence de salevert 20 ans
habitante de saint-émilchrevvreuse qui
pratique de nombreux sports alors les
critères de sélection pour le
département des Yvelines ce département
a voulu récompenser l'investissement
dans le monde associatif et sportif et
promouvoir aussi les valeurs de
citoyenneté et de courage ces éclaireurs
seront côté de grands sportifs de
grandes personnalités on ne connais pas
aujourd'hui leur nom ça sera dévoilé
d'ici le le mois d'avril est-ce que vous
validez tout simplement cette démarche
du du département un grand OUI Nicolas
oui oui c'est voilà comment faire
participer les les Françaises et les
Français à à cette année olympique en
fait à inclure en fait les les les
personnes les habitants et les
concitoyens dans dans cette grande fête
que seront les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques ben voilà ce qui est bien
c'est queon voit que ce n'est pas l'état
et le pouvoir central qui qui contrôle
tout mais il y a la décentralisation qui
fonctionne dans dans cette attribution
et là c'est le le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines qui choisit ses acteurs
parce que Ben le Conseil départemental
est au plus proche des habitants il
connaît ceux qui s'engagent il y a même
des personnes qui sont qui bénéficient
de dispositifs départementaux je pense à
cette jeune jeune Manon oui Man est
accompagné par l'IDE soci à aide sociale
à l'enfance c'est un dispositif d'aide
et d'accompagnement pour les enfants et
les jeunes qui qui sont en difficulté
ben voilà voilà un bon exemple en fait
de Ben de du fonctionnement de la
décentralisation à la française voilà on
est purement dans cet esprit de
génération 2024 de donner aussi un
certain héritage c'est convit le plus
grand nombre finalement pour pour ces
Jeux Olympiques on a suffisamment dit
ici notamment que que la perspective des
JO à Paris manquait d'une dimension de
cette vraie dimension populaire avec le
prix des places notamment et de de des
packages qui étaient proposés pour
pouvoir se réjouir de de cette vraie
dimension humaine sportive et et
populaire avec avec vraiment l'ancrage
l'ancrage local yvelinois avec des des
vrais sportifs en gros et de rentrer de
faire rentrer leur quotidien dans le
dans le trajet de la flamme à quelques à
quelques jours de l'ouverture officielle
des Jio le 26 euh choix dans la date
choix des choix des candidates choix des
candidats on est on est vraiment dans le
dans le dans le le port le port des
ivelines au plus au plus haut point et
puis avec toutes les épreuves qui vont
être qui vont être organisés dans
lesines on va on va passer là des bons
moments populaires il y en aura il y en
aura d'autres qui seront réservés je dis
pas j'en dis pas plus qui sont réservés
à ceux qui à ceux qui peuvent mais au
moins avec cela on a on a l'image et le
sport des evelines qui sont qui sont
bien représentés Nicolas ce qui est
fantastique c'est aussi vous avez donné
les âges c'est transgénérationnel en
fait on a une jeune fille de 15 ans on a
quelqu'un qui
a 92s 94 ans 93 voilà c'est c'est génial
en fait de faire participer toutes les
Françaises et tous les Français à à ce
moment en fait ce moment de fête à la
gloire du pays en fait juste pour cette
information donc le département des
ivines a nmé a nommé ses éclaireur la
région î-de-fance aussi on retrouve
notamment l'arbitre féminine Stéphanie
frappard qui n'arbitre pas que les
sections féminines mais bien sûr aussi
en en Ligue 1 il y a aussi Frédéric Marz
juste pour citer puce qu'on a on a déjà
on l'a déjà rencontré à tv78 s'occupe de
l'association women safe qui vient en
aide aux femmes victimes de violence à
Saint-Germain en alors je disais tout à
l'heure le nom des personnalités des
sportifs et pour le moment tenu secret
le comité d'organisation de Paris 2024
va dévoiler les noms d'ici le mois
d'avril qui vous rêvez de voir dans les
ivelines porter la flamme olympique
quelques bruit de couloir ou avec
quelques sportif sportif et sportive on
a déjà quelques noms qui sont qui sont
sortis parce que juste elles ont fait
fuiter ou ils ont fait fuiter le fait
qu'ils aent été choisis alors c'est qui
vous pouvez le dire non je je vais leur
laisser je leur laisserai le justement
le bonheur de l'annoncer officiellement
et après en rêve en rêve on en a on en a
quand même pas mal moi un petit des
petits rugbyman
rugbyman né ou formés dans les Yvelines
et qui sont qui jouent maintenant ici
ici ou ailleurs ça serait peut-être pas
mal bon on en reparlera sur la page
rugby par exempleo all au bar voilà
exactement voilà ou un petit ou un
richavanc comme çare pas mal au-delà des
des porteurs moi on en a parlé cette
semaine en rédaction Grégor j'allis vous
demander un pronostique je pense que je
vois je vois où vous voulez envenir
c'est surtout moi ce que je veux ça à
voir aujourd'hui mais on aura ça sera
vraiment au dernier moment quand au
moment où on verra la cérémonie c'est
celui qui va allumer la flamme et la
vasque olympique et voilà
c'est enfin moi zineddin Z zineddin
Zidane pardon ce serait juste
exceptionnel de le voir allumer la
flamme enfin la vasque olympique lors de
la cérémonie d'ouverture Zidane Marie
José Perrec David Douillet c'est les
premiers noms qui qui circule mais voilà
le le Comité olympique tient pour le
moment garde pour le moment le secret et
pour vous est-ce que vous avez
pronostique est-ce que vous voyez un
grand sportif peut-être de deux sportif
ce ceux que vous avez cité ah pour pour
le pour la vasque euh c'est presque de
l'évidence dans ce ce que vous avez cité
pronostic difficile difficile à dire
parce que c'est c'est quand même c'est
quand même un poste et une fonction qui
est hautement symbolique donc des
champions olympiques on en a on en a
encore quand même pas mal je m'y
risquerai pas là j'ai n'empêche que Z
Zidan ça sera un beau pied de nez aux
Anglais voilà par rapport à 2012
puisqueen 2012 c'est David Beckham qui
avait allumé la vasque olympique donc ce
serait logique quoi et pour vous ça
représente quoi ça sera la dernière
question sur cette thématique on parle
beaucoup des Jeux Olympiques des
épreuves la flamme le relais de la
flamme olympique c'est quand même
symbolique c'est c'est une belle fête
avant le début de ces épreuves c'est le
protocole c'est le protocole on sait que
c'est c'est l'avant Jeux Olympiques on
sait que ça y est ça arrive en fait dès
que la flamme est allumée à
c'est on se dit c'est bientôt
c'est le côté universel que que je
noterai avec le justement là c'est tous
les sports sont sous cette même
symbolique et tous ces sportifes et
sportifs sont les relais de de la
candidature de de des jeux à Paris et de
tous ceux qui vont y participer de tous
ceux qui vont être spectateurs avertis
et et enthousiasme de cet événement et
pour juste céonie d'ouverture c'est 3h
moi je depuis allez 2000 j'ai le
souvenir de 2004 de 2004 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui moi je suis resté tout les
3hures devant la télé à chaque cérémonie
d'ouverture que ce soit jeu d'été et jeu
d'hiver d'ailleurs donc relais de la
flamme olympique qui va passer par
plusieurs pays dans toute la France
aussi et dans les iveline ce sera le 23
juillet prochain il y a aussi la flamme
paralympique he n'oublions pas les Jeux
paralympiques qui suivront ces Jeux
Olympiques fin août début septembre elle
passera le 27 août cette flamme
paralympique à Oudan et au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yveline et
pareil on on connaît les premiers
éclaireurs choisis par le département
des Yvelines la paracycliste sur route
de 21 ans Jeane le pêcheur il y aura
aussi Quentin Boudeville qui est en
balleur fauteuil en bal fauteuil à Oudan
c'est l'heure de l'envoler Nicolas
d'Andri alors ce n'est pas sans émotion
que je vous passe le flambau justement
voilà pour pour cet envolé de quoi
allez-vous nous parler aujourd'hui et
bien envolons-nous on va s'envoler à
Saint-Germain en les triste destiné pour
cette soupe préfecture des ivelin
plusieurs fois relégué au second plan de
l'histoire berceau royal du Moyen-Âge de
la Renaissance jusqu'au 17e siècle et la
décision du roi soleil de transférer la
maternité des rois de France à
Versailles voilà sa première relégation
à Saint-Germain les regardez ensuite à
la fin de la Première Guerre mondiale le
traité de paix avec l'Allemagne a été
signé à Versailles et le traité de paix
avec l'autrich hongerie a été signé à
Saint-Germain h encore une fois relégué
au second plan et encore aujourd'hui he
le PSG a décidé de transférer son centre
d'entraînement ben du Camp des Loges de
Saint-Germain en la à poissie pauvre
Saint-Germain en la mais alors attention
aujourd'hui solennellement je vous le
dis on va remettre l'église au milieu du
village rendons à Saint-Germain en lait
ce qui appartient à Saint-Germain en
lait les lettres de noblesse à cette
cité royale bis des Yvelines la première
est en versaill mais c'est pas
Versailles ici c'est Saint-Germain en
alors Saint-Germain enlé reste une cité
maternelle sportive c'est le cas
d'Amélie moresmo née le 5 juillet Ju
1979 à Saint-Germain en la Caroline
Garcia née le 16 octobre 1993 à
Saint-Germain en la ça vous en smatche
un coup hein les gars c'est vrai et
alors le tournoi dessination 2024 va
débuter bientôt Saint-Germain enlè va vu
naître cette commune a vu naître
attention le 6 novembre
1998 Mathieu Jalibert le numéro 10 du 15
de France c'est peu connu mais pourtant
oui Jalibert et ivelinois de naissance
après avoir assuré rôle de numéro 10
durant la Coupe du Monde 2023 Matthieu
Jalibert devrait être le titulaire au
poste de demi d'ouverture du 15 de
France pour débutter face à l'Irlande le
2 février prochain la destinée de
doublure a basculé lors de la blessure
de Romain tamac juste avant le Mondial
Mathieu Jalibert est propulsé numéro 1
au poste de numéro 10 alors qu'il a
toujours endossé le rôle de remplaçant
11 titularisation en 22 matchs depuis
2020 jusqu'au début de la Coupe du monde
avec 30 sélections à 25 ans le
Saint-Germain is de naissance réalise un
début de saison avec l'Union Bordeaux B
mais qui est tout simplement
exceptionnel Mathieu Jalibert participe
largement à la réussite de Bordeau bgle
actuellement 2e du Top 14 et qualifié
pour les phases finales de Coupe
d'Europe il dynamise le jeu anime la
ligne d'attaque fantastique de Bordeau
bgle plus qu'une doublure avec à ses
côté Maxime Luc il fait partie des
leaders de ce 15 de France alors
martolons-le Mathieu Jalibert est né à
Saint-Germain en la certes il n'a pas
grandi mais c'est un enfant
saint-germainois qui remis au au premier
plan cette ville des iblines bravo
Nicolas pour cet en comme Matthieu
Jalibert du rôle de remplaçant vous êtes
passé titulaire aussi dans cette
émission et merci pour pour cet envé un
petit avis c'est c'est c'est très bien
de mettre remettre l'église au niveau du
au milieu du village avec encore une
fois des nombreux atouts de des ivelines
de cette de cette jolie ville
effectivement au départ au départ ville
au premier plan et puis qui qui part
différ truchement après derrière de
l'histoire et passé relégué au deuxième
plan mais bon on voit que on voit qu'il
il y a quand même encore matière à en
parler de cette jolie ville ce joli
château c'est puis au-delà du fait que
c'est une une ville où il fait très bon
vivre au dire de ceux qui y sont et sur
Mathieu jaliibert Matthieu jaliibert je
je suis pas je suis pas fan de la
première heure mais il faut quand même
il faut quand même reconnaître que qu'il
il a vraiment pris pris sa chance si on
peut on peut parler de ça euh concernant
la la la blessure de roman entamac avec
un un joueur qui est un joueur qui est
final qui est un drôle de bonhomme mais
qui c'est vrai là depuis ce début de
saison là porte porte aussi participe à
l'élan collectif de l'UBB et qui qui qui
donne de nombreux de nombreuses
garanties avec ses nombreux succès et je
pense que de toute façon on va vivre un
un tournoi destination un petit peu
particulier euh avec notre
charnière fétiche en moins avec un roman
entamac en 10 qui qu'on vaiss 100 et
puis un un Antoine Dupont qui lui a fait
a fait le choix du rugby à 7 sur le sur
les Jeux Olympiques donc on va voir on
va voir un un tournoi spécial si
effectivement Fabien Galtier surfe sur
la vague il va mettre la charnière la
charnière bordolaise pour pour démarrer
face à l'Irlande et puis on a juste
derrière celle de celle du Racing 92 qui
pousse derrière avec avec Gibert et et
le garek qui pourront faire plus que
supplayer si jamais il y a quoi que ce
soit au niveau de la charnière
bordelaise Nicolas racontez-nous la
jeunèse de cet envolée pourquoi vous
avez voulu parler de ce sujet ben c'est
vrai qu'on parle souvent de Caroline
Garcia qui est née à Saint-Germain olé
mais qui n'a pas grandi enfin qui a fait
peut-être quelques années mais elle a
pas été formé dans les mais en tout
casintgainigin j'ai vou replacer et dire
que maie jaliber aussi était né à
Saint-Germain en d'un père militaire qui
a été ensite muté en Nouvelle-Calédonie
et il a commencé le rugby à Numa avant
de revenir en métropole et il a été
formé à Bordeaux à l'Union
bordeauxgle donc oui il est bien
yvelinois de naissance Mathie Jalibert
on a d'autres des rugby i des
rugbyvelinois formé pour certains à
versaill qui commence bien formé
peut-être qu'on en dira un mot dans dans
un instant et sur sur le tournoi
destination vous le voyez comment ben
écoutez le tournoi destination moi je
prsin je l'ai vécu au plus près la Coupe
du monde j'ai senti j'ai vu des joueurs
meurtrriis juste après le le match de
l'Afrique du Sud je pense notamment à
greégory aldrit qui s'est présenté face
au
journalistes du monde entier parce qu'il
y avait des journalistes du monde entier
qui s'est présenté en conférence de en
zone mixte et qui était mais effondré
d'ailleurs c'est un joueur qui a pris 2
mois de repos qui a coupé complètement
avec le sport avant de reprendre début
janvier avec son club écoutez justement
par rapport à ce côté meurtri ben je
pense que les joueurs vont être
mobilisés la grande majorité des 34
joueurs qui ont été convoqués
actuellement à marcousi Ben ont
participer à la Coupe du Monde il y a un
vent de jeunesse aussi insufflé par
Fabien Galtier Fabien Galtier qui a
aussi un nouveau staff donc oui moi je
vois je vois les Français de toute façon
le premier match sera déterminant mais
je vois bien les Français performer
durant ce tournoi destination pour
effacer justement ce qui s'est passé à
la Coupe du monde peut-être avec une
petite surprise versaillaise ouais oui
oui de de derrière les fagot en fonction
du ça serait aussi avec le au gré au gré
des blessures ou des tests des tests
mais effectivement il se bruisse que que
notre petit protégé du Stade Français
Paris formé à Versailles les au Baret
serait pas très loin de rejoindre de
rejoindre le le staff de l'équipe de
France vu le début de saison qui nous
fait avec le Stade Français Paris c'est
pas étonnant pas étonnant du tout dans
tous les cas en terme de pronostic on va
être fixé dès le premier match dè dès le
France-Irlande du vendredi du vendredi 2
février on sera on sera fixé
méfions-nous quand même aussi des
Anglais euh qui quoi qu' dise quoi qu'on
dise est la meilleure équipe du tournoi
destination la meilleure équipe
européenne en Coupe du monde sur la
récente ça peut faire mal de le dire
mais c'est mais c'est un fait donc les
écoc aussi attention é
bien sûr nos amis écossais aussi c'est
c'est les seuls qui ont qui ont qui ont
pas de grand chè depuis très très très
longtemps les Écossais et donc bon pour
le petit chauvinisme aussi de de voir de
voir l'équipe de France conquérrente il
y a beaucoup d'absen côté irlandais
aussi il y a il y a il y a quatre ou
cinq titulaires
en en puissance qui sont absents
notamment sur le premier match nous on a
quelques blessés aussi depuis et
quelques absents dont dont Antoine
Dupont absent de taille mais on doit
pouvoir tirer notre épinle du jeu aucune
chance pour
l'Italie alors ça je sais pas juste pour
Gonzalo kessada qui qui a pris qui a
pris la exact et puis il y a h capozo
aussi la star italienne juste pour
compléter les propos de de Pierre
Chevalier à propos de léob Barret c'est
une information dévoilée ce matin par
Midi Olympique repris notamment par actu
rugby léob Barret serait convoqué à
marcousi jeudi pour poursuivre la
préparation du 15 de France sachant
qu'en fait la nouvelle organisation
aujourd'hui en entre la Fédération et
les clubs de Top 14 veut que l'équipe de
France libère certains joueurs pour
pouvoir jouer ce weekend puisqu'il y a
une journée de Top 14 le championnat de
France se poursuit alors que l'équipe de
France prépare le tournoi destination et
donc certains joueurs seraient appelés
en complément pour poursuivre la
préparation des matchs et léob Baret
feraiit partie de de ces joueurs là
voilà on espère qu' ser avec un gros
avantage c'est qu'il joue 10 12 15 et
donc il il a il couvre pas mal de postes
derrière et ça peut ça peut donner pas
mal de solutions pour nous donnera de
prochain sujet pour le SOP on va
terminer justement son ceci on parle
sport avec une
découverte et parler d'une discipline
qui commence à se faire connaître c'est
le wakeboard et les sport du wakeboard
français est ivelinois Tibo laagel a
seulement 16 ans il se lance dans ce
sport de glisse il y a 2 ans ce sportif
originaire de Vau sursène a découvert
cette discipline à l'âge de 14 ans
depuis sa progression est fulgurante en
seulement 2 ans il gagne le championnat
de France deux fois d'affilé on écoute
il y a 3 ans je me disais pas champion
de France et encore moins une deuxème
année de plus participer au championnat
du monde participer au championnat
d'Europe avec l'équipe de France ça fait
beaucoup de choses en si peu de temps
même si il a été sélectionné en équipe
de France livelinois reste prudent il se
laisse 2 ans pour évoluer après son bac
en poche l'objectif pour lui sera de
rejoindre la ville d'Orlando en Floride
quelqu'un qui à Orlando en plus en ce
moment de tv78 pour continuer son
apprentissage et pourquoi pas tenter une
carrière professionnelle on va termin
juste avec un petit avis sur bah cette
ascension fulgurante quand même comme
quoi rien n'est impossible dans le sport
Nicolas oui puis en plus c'est un sport
qui est assez technique on sait que
notre Mister météo national d'Alor quadb
s'est testé au wbard et il s'en est bien
sorti même si ben comme je disais c'est
très technique pour notamment juste
sortir de l'eau et rester debout sur la
planche donc ouais c'est assez
impressionnant j'avais testé je crois
que j'étais sorti une seule fois de l'au
C avec le W surf qui est une discipline
similaire Pier pour pour une fois c'est
c'est pas c'est pas là où on attendait
les ivelines éventuellement de sortir un
champion un champion de wboard si loin
de la mer aussi loinon après c'est donc
c'est sur les cours d'eau les cours d'au
yvelinois Scine au bras de Scine c'était
pas forcément évident d'imaginer ça mais
comme quoi le le ça doit être l'air
l'air et l'eau l'eau des Yvelines qui
qui est propice à tout type de vocation
sportive pourvu qu'il aille le plus loin
possible
ça le fait sortir aussi de sa zone de
confort et d'aller d'aller aux
États-Unis là où là où sont là où sont
finalement à priori tous les meilleurs
ça peut-être ça met peut-être le le le
le doigt sur sur le fait que a priori on
a pas non plus toutes les infrastructure
et la culture sportive dans tous les
sports pour pouvoir accompagner nos
champions et nos championnes on a vu on
peut se baigner dans la scène dans les
exactement j'ais dire je pense qu'il est
pas malade aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'il y a pas trop de risque en tout cas
on est bien loin de Paris n'importe qu
c'est ça parce que on rappelle que à
Paris normalement est prévu des épreuves
sont prévu des épreuves dans la scène
merci messieurs de m'avoir accompagné
tout au long de cette émission qui
touche à sa fin et on va terminer comme
d'habitude avec une citation alors juste
avant de vous la donner un petit hommage
avec le Kaiser France Becken Bower qui
s'en est allé tout comme la légende
italienne Gigi Riva les deux hommes
s'étaient d'ailleurs affrontés lors du
match du siècle dernier RFA Italie en
demi-finale de la Coupe du Monde 1970
une rencontre légendaire où Becken Bower
avait carrément terminé le bras en
échare alors pour venir à la citation
l'Allemand qui a été aussi président du
Bayern Munich avait répondu de cette
manière à la question est-ce que les
joueurs du barne sont dopés oui avait-il
répondu à la bière blanche et au reti
port je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase et je vous dis à très vite sur
[Musique]
tv78